welcome to she doesn't read the news
because it is controlled by the soviet
regime
you read what we want you to read
good morning vietnam there we go she's
the one introducing
this week's episode hey alice nguyen
hello christina
welcome to she doesn't read the news
have you seen good morning vietnam i
think someone watched it once
on a plane that i was sitting next to
them and so i watched it over their
shoulder
that's a good way to watch movies yeah i
don't think i have much of the nuances
of the films
i remember watching don john the uh
joseph gordon-levitt film about him
being a porn star
no no he's addicted to porn he's
addicted to porn and
it was quite graphic a plain film
yeah and you were near a child no i
don't think on that one i was
really but also only certain planes have
those disclaimers that say
please be aware that people around you
may be able to see this and mine did not
but what happened was there was a guy
next to me who was just watching it
and then halfway through he goes what
movie is that and i said
don john he goes oh and then he started
watching it but really the only thing
you get from just watching that movie
without sound is
lots of sex and boobies he wanted the
sex and boobies yeah
you know and he'd already seen them but
you wouldn't see them a second time yeah
yeah
a comedian we both admire adam hess has
a very good routine about
seeing a german man on a plane watching
the sixth sense
and he says you only watch the sixth
sense if you haven't seen the sixth
sense so
it's clear that he didn't know it so he
watched to see how
the german man reacted to the twist
spoilers um yeah well that's the thing i
can't i can't
even show you even in a visual medium if
you're watching rather than listening i
can't show you the face he does because
it's just such a funny face but
rest assured he has a very funny face go
follow adam hess on instagram on twitter
he's incredible um sixth sense weirdly
it's just like i read the script of it
and it is the most
extraordinary script and you read it and
you just think oh my god wow that
you know this person's a genius but this
is the same
man who did the happening like i don't
know what happened how
how he could have had such fluke well so
the sixth sense i believe
he spent a long time writing and as far
as i remember
the twist didn't come until the 10th or
10th
that he figured it out so
yeah i don't know i don't know maybe we
only have one masterwork inside us
i have heard that i have a friend who
always tells me in gloomy and depressed
tones that we only have 10 good years of
work
and you just you know don't know when
that 10 years will fall
good as long as they didn't follow it up
with ages 4 to 14.
but i i um discount that because
you look at dickens's um works
and he wrote tons of really famous books
for years
and he's not just rewriting the same
book over and over again there's enough
no i i would say i mean okay it is
extraordinary how many just really
famous books
dickens wrote right he wrote great
expectations bleak house
oliver twist david copperfield tale of
two cities which is the third
biggest selling book of all time yeah uh
challenging cities
um nicholas nickleby um and then
then oh hard times is also really fast
these are all books that i've heard of
yeah this is what i mean he has just
written so many
bangers um and that's before we even get
to the slightly deeper cut ones like i'm
not sure everyone's heard of little
dorit
but the pickwick papers yeah right but
um
so that's what i'm saying and then you
also have like jimmy right and you know
so that there's authors who write for
much longer than
is that the that's the author of three
musketeers and counter monte cristo
yes and others you do recommend those
don't you i mean you recommend dickens
and dumas
they're both great any other authors or
are they
no those are the only two authors i've
ever read or will ever read alice win
cancel i have to say that dead white men
are my favorite writers
it's because there were so many of them
there's a wider field to choose from
yeah there's many of them to choose from
alice has a a rule that she sticks to
most of the time which is don't read a
book unless it's by someone who's dead
because if it's lasted beyond their
lifetime must be a really good book
you're uh you're misstating it um i had
this rule until i was 22.
so then when i was 22 i suddenly was
like i'm going to try some of these
alive authors i've been hearing so much
about
i met edward st albans once uh is that
even sorry
is that a name a place or the name of
someone's horse
it is a um sort of i think he
won or was nominated for the book of
prize a couple times he's a you know
famous author
and i was like 19 and i was at his house
for whatever reason having tea
and um it's never suspicious when famous
creatives have 19 year olds of their
house he was lovely
anyway um and i
i said to him i've never read one of
your books because i only read
books by authors who are dead which is a
rude thing to say but you know
uh imagine that after a show someone
comes up to me and goes oh
i see you're a comedian i i didn't
actually watch because i only watched
dead comedians
if you only watch dead comedians you can
watch a lot of great meetings right
robin williams good morning vietnam sam
kinnison i don't think you can
no see i think it's a bad comparison
because i think old comedy really
ages badly uh accurate yes like
like a stand-up comedy routine from the
1960s is ridiculous
i know there's like there's some more
sal or kind of you know
woody allen has great stand-up comedy
from back then they're still well chris
i can't believe
you're a pedophile anyway
so this guy i said this to you know
famous successful author i remember he
was just very
suave about it he was like i'm sorry i
can't oblige you by dying
i'm glad you finally figured that out
because that was just
yeah that was when i'd met you and you
were in the midst of planning to
assassinate jk rowling just so you could
read the harry potter
the reason for it was i just felt like
the cannon was so enormous and
i just wanted to get to grips with it
and um you know i'm
glad that i have i have a handle on it
now what on balance of um weighing up
the scale
more better books by dead authors or
better books by live authors i have a
i have a preference for dead authors
that's the kind of hit rate if you
picked a random book by a dead author or
a random book and a live author but see
it's not a fair comparison because
a book by a dead author generally
speaking
is still in print 50 years after the
author died like that's the kind of
books that i'm reading by dead authors
whereas you just don't have that safety
net with books by contemporary authors
uh you know you just don't know
if they are good enough to last the test
of time whereas almost all the books you
read by dead authors even if you don't
like them
the fact they have stood the test of
time means that there is a reason that
lots of people liked it
yeah um but this is a little bit how i
feel about bestsellers i think i kind of
just believe
that when a ton of people enjoy a work
of literature
it doesn't matter whether or not the
work of literature is literate like
literary or good
what matters is that you're learning
something about the massive group of
people who enjoyed the book like with 50
shades of grey
the book itself not good but it's still
interesting to read it because you learn
about people
yeah it teaches you how horny women in
their 40s and 50s are
on the subject of great works of art we
watched probably the finest piece of art
ever produced
this week didn't we anyone who's been
checking out alice wins instagram
stories
titanic we watched titanic ah
it really holds up all right chris was
like i don't want to watch this four
hour
leonardo dicaprio film it is very long
but it is
40 minutes of that is an old woman
talking about how great her boobs used
to look
true but you have to admit that you
could not cut
a single second of that film because it
is pristine and perfect in its entirety
i fully disagree with you you have to
admit everyone has to admit
why is there the framing story i
understand i mean the skill with that
film is we all know what happened to the
titanic therefore james cameron makes it
so that we care about what happens to
the characters and that's that's a
clever way of doing it rather than
will the boat sink we know the bird's
gonna sing how will the bow sing it's
gonna break in two and
you know um it was a good film i did
enjoy it excellent billy zanes very good
he's so so great i would definitely
choose him over leo
really yeah because he's rich well he's
rich he buys tacky diamonds he buys her
very large diamonds
yeah i mean he's definitely got an anger
problem
uh yeah but you know i just think um
i think i'd be fine with him you and
your brother were talking about how
billy zane was in the mummy as
imhotep that's not correct is it not no
it's not him it's a different actor
they're both bold did you see that this
week they voted on the world's sexiest
man
i want to get back to that but i don't
think i watched the mummy returns or the
mummy
with enough focus to be able to really
have made a
i think you're really quoting my brother
yeah to be honest if you think billy
zane
looks like the guy who plays immatep
that would explain why the people who
made the mummy returns
think that the rock looks like the
abomination that they animate
for the scorpion king at the end of the
movie i thought it's the worst piece of
cgi it is pretty bad wait but tell me
about this
hot bold man there was a there was a
vote they did a survey for the world's
sexiest bald man
fans of stanley tucci were very angry
because he did not win
he should have been up there for sure oh
definitely um
prince william won
the backlash is that he has not accepted
the fact that he's bold
yeah he doesn't lean into it what i've
always heard is that if you're going
bald you've got to shave it off and get
buff
those are your options i feel like
that's the thing you're a seed you're
planting for the future when my
follicles start to drop out you're like
well you know what they say
get that razor and get benching bruv i
don't know
this is what this is what they say there
are there are many sexy bald men i'm
trying to think who my sexiest bold man
would be
i mean i'm surprised is the rock balled
he gives off boulder
yeah he doesn't give her full vibes yeah
yeah how's prince william beating him
the rock is way sexy i think
we've talked about this prince william
has like a hot
18 year old version of him in him
so when we look at old prince william we
still kind of see young prince william
i wonder if that happens like your
parents will often say oh she's so
beautiful
and that's i wonder if that's because
they're thinking of them when they saw
them in their prime like if you see
sophia loren
in her primary like she's stunning and
then you'd always see sophia lorraine as
that in the same way that you know
couples as they age presumably still see
each other the way they were when they
first met i think i think a lot of the
time they do yeah
so maybe maybe that's what's going on
with prince william hmm
yeah well well done prince william uh
i'm glad that you are
the world's sexiest bold man i don't
think it makes sense for him to beat out
stanley tucci
tucci has got so much charm and he's
such range as well
devil wears prada hunger games he's an
easier julian julia he's in easy a
oh he's great yeah more film chat we
watched um watch reservoir dogs
yeah now that is one of my favorite
movies it's a movie that i i really love
um you had never seen it and you were
very kind in letting me show at you
what's your opinion on reservoir i
thought it was just fine i quite enjoyed
it
um i have a fairly ambivalent
relationship with
quentin tarantino i i don't love him i
mean more movie chat because all we've
done this week is seemingly watch
television speak for yourself i read
david copperfield
fair enough fair enough but uh did it
have
a horse jumping off a tower into the
ocean landing on its back
no it did not sadly we watched the james
bond ripoff the unauthorized james bond
never say never again
in it there is a scene where james bond
and
is it kim basinger at that point yeah
jump off
like a turkish sort of
unclear which country that they're in um
middle eastern ish they jump off a tower
on a horse and you're like oh that's
clearly right so we have a couple of
friends who are vets and
two different vets have confirmed this
for us because the first question i
always ask about is
which animals do you dislike the most
and they always say
horses and both the vets i've asked
about this specifically were like well
the problem with horses is they just
kind of seem to want to die like they
come in
and they just like you know they've all
they've done is like spraying an
ankle and then you have to fight so hard
to keep them alive
because they just die at the drop of a
hat their legs are just toothpicks
they're like these
giant rotund bodies and then
flimsy straw cleaner legs they're very
pretty but
yeah no they're not um they're not like
sturdy creatures actually so the chance
of that horse
not being injured by that stunt seems
slim so that scene
basically they composite
a horse falling from a tower you're like
that's not real obviously
and then they just cut to some water and
you see a horse with riders on it
fall into the sea the horse landing on
its back
into the sea and that scene is banned in
the uk they
censor that out because the rspca rules
society for the prevention of cruelty to
animals
um i love that it's nice that the queen
is the sponsor of that she's like that's
my cause animals
um hey do you want to sponsor this
movement against racism shut up leave
um they they cut out because they can't
guarantee that the horse willingly did
the jump the horse did not willingly do
the jump
the horse stuntman for that said i love
horses i have nothing but respect for
them but this horse would not
jump into the water so we hoist him up
in a container
just opened the door then tipped him out
they tipped him 30 feet into the water
a horse can't consent to jumping 30 feet
into water no i mean horses consent to
jumping over little hedges and they die
from that all the time in like the grand
national
i guess i guess the the amount of
consent we can give to horses is limited
because
um we own them
that's how things work yeah exactly
exactly chris i don't know if you
remember this
but when god created the garden of eden
he made us the masters of the earth
yeah i don't believe in that
the other big event this week was that
uh this boy got a thousand micrograms of
moderna
pumped into his bloodstream yeah our
county has
vaccinated just [ __ ] everyone they've
been doing a really good job um we were
on the
uh the walmart waste avoidance protocol
list which the acronym for is whap so i
did turn up i was like i'm on the wap
list
where ass [ __ ] and they were like sir
that's uh everyone's made that joke
already
um i it was it was very exciting
um in six weeks roughly i can go out and
make out strangers make out with
straight really is that permission you
heard it here first lovely people
i'm gonna shave my head i'm gonna go out
pretend to be stanley tucci gonna get
all that
lip locking anyone who's not vaccinated
i hope you get your vaccine
soon do check out those waste avoidance
protocol lists call up your walmart and
say hey i'd love to get on that
um because if they're going to be thrown
away you might as well use them
so that's exciting um before we start
the news we do actually have a sponsor
now for the podcast
um i don't you know we're not being paid
for this it just comes to mind
microsoft yes it's funny how much i've
been thinking about microsoft lately
yeah
great great surface uh laptop
this is recorded on a macbook that's
often why the sound goes all [ __ ]
yeah we should we show you microsoft
just cancel apple
and only use products yeah let's let's
stop putting this out on apple podcast
on that also i'm taking down the bill
gates wrap i think it's too
mean i've just had this urge king bill
bow down before
big old bg um let's let's get on with
the news this week
i think you know what the biggest news
story this week is i do the suez canal
the sioux
s oh boy
full of memes as far as i can tell it is
nothing but memes
yeah which is why it's such a good news
story yes that is the best kind of news
story is this broke at the start of the
week and i immediately wrote it down as
that's gonna be the big news story this
week because there's no way they're
moving this boat
and it's just got worse and worse um
really also we were very
kindly sent in by a lovely listener so
thank you lovely listener
um a little heads up that there was some
bred lick poetry
already about this which i had found
independent you'd already found i
replied them and said alice has already
told me this thereby
defeating the purpose of the podcast and
they replied respect the concept
so but as far as i remember it was
um my name is boat and when i'm tired
but shipping work is still required and
all i want
is little snooze i turn to side i block
the shoes
yeah it's great in it love it bit of
bread like bit of sue's blocking
uh i really hope the people in the boat
are okay
because the emotional strain of like
it's hilarious for all of us but like
are they fine i just want them to be
fine yeah um so i read an interview with
some sailors on another ship and they
said look we feel
uh you know real sorry for our
counterparts i think it's 14 indian
sailors who are on that
boat and it's like look this isn't their
fault it was a sandstorm it was wind
although someone to do with the egyptian
government has now said
uh we actually don't think it was just
the weather we think it was human error
so there's some incompetence there but
um
yeah for the last few days essentially
the suez canal the
main artery of global shipping trade
so the sewers canal is it tell me where
it is
geographically is um through egypt
i believe oh is that the uh the way you
pronounce it yes well i am an
egyptian egypt okay so it's through
egypt uh
i have i have like a hazy memory
that the british built it am i wrong
probably we did everything
really good in the world the empire was
overall
fantastic for everyone let me google
this because i feel like something
i feel like there may have been a bit of
like oh sorry don't mind us we just like
to build quick canal right here so the
suez canal was built in the mid-1800s
by the suez canal company which was
founded by a frenchman
and the thing yeah that's how they sound
and the thing that's a little dodgy
about it i think
is that it was mainly controlled by
european shareholders until like the
1956. kind of weird isn't it if someone
just
cut away a bunch of your land just to
build a thoroughfare through and we're
like that's
ours now we we get the money from that
yeah
yeah um and so
then yeah they the president of egypt
seized control during the suez
crisis which is suez control i which i
think was uh
in the crown oh okay cool um
maybe anyway um but yeah so so now all
these ships are going around the tip of
africa yeah so the differences i have
here the alternative route for shipping
when it's blocked so if you go from
going through the serious canal from
taiwan to rotterdam which is you know
big port city
it's 10 000 nautical miles it takes 25
and a half days if you use the suez
it's 13 and a half thousand nautical
miles takes 34 days if you go the other
way which is around the the horn of
africa the cape a good hope
you go right along the bottom um that's
a big difference especially because
i learned that apparently they're
burning a million dollars worth of fuel
a day
so adding on nine more days is 9 million
that's bonkers to me a lot of fuel
have they considered sailboats yeah
uh yes donald your order will be there
in 2023
sailboats alice win what is this the
cape of good hope is really choppy
waters
right okay cool that's really really bad
sailing
if you're sailing really bad bad with
five a's there from alice win
were you in your head were you going ba
da what
bad sailing pirates captain phillips had
to go around the cape of good hope
in in that book in that book in the film
which
uh my brother-in-law told me was a
rom-com about a man falling in love on a
boat
you could say it's not develops
i was lied to you you were lied to decay
to watch that
i told you breath of war dogs was
actually a sequel to homewood bound
i'm always being tricked yeah um but
that ship the the ever given which is
confusing because every picture i've
seen
of it has evergreen written down the
side but it's called the ever given
weird right there's something going on i
think this goes deeper than we thought
it is as long as the empire state
building is tall
that tells you how big it is is it
bigger than the titanic um
i would assume so that's very big isn't
it yeah the titanic is very large it's a
ship of dreams
it's unsinkable mate it's unthinkable um
but yeah so basically for those of you
that didn't know we've probably been
talking for about five minutes about
something you've not
really understood a big old container
ship
turned sideways blocked the canal
there's now a hold up of maybe 300 ships
either side 50 ships a day go through
that canal which is 10
of the world's global trade they must
have so many things on them these ships
yeah well
that's the problem if if they can't move
it with tugboats or with tiny little
diggers
then they are going to have to dig a new
canal
well the first one took 10 years i'm not
entirely sure they have to get in a
frenchman again
the guy who did it resurrect the suez
canal company
i know i am a boulangerie now what is
happening
i um i was reading how they're going to
have to remove the containers
from the ship which will require getting
a crane that can go 200 meters high
which is going to take several weeks so
i mean let's hope
that they can move it it's all quite fun
and jokes to us now but i wonder
if it won't be when i've i've read that
it may cause another
toilet paper crisis oh dear which none
of us
can go through again yeah who would have
thought the knock-on effects because the
first sewers crisis different than you
know the
the war between i think egypt and israel
that blocked the suez canal lasted for
like seven years they bought that
but now it's just a boat and we can't
get any tp
yeah i wonder if everyone in sort of
south africa is going to make a ton of
money from like stop-over trips
i wonder i wonder i mean if you go
around you don't have to pay any money
true right there's no you know maybe
people have to refuel or something
i my favorite tweet i saw this week was
someone i can't remember the name but uh
it was it was imagine being the captain
of the first ship to go through the suez
canal after it's unblocked
and realizing you have the opportunity
to do the funniest thing in history
i'm like yeah that would be that would
be wonderful
it wouldn't it would destroy global
trade devastating
so i've read a lot of things of people
being like
one boat is doing more damage to
global trade and capitalism than like
years of like occupy wall street or
whatever
yeah i mean i did i did see some posts
saying you know oh it shows the
fragility of global infrastructure and
you go
well that's like saying when a car
accident has a pile up and blocks a
motorway and there's tailbacks it shows
the fragility of roads like
yes of course if something is blocked it
doesn't oh this
huge buildup of cholesterol in your
artery shows the fragility of your heart
but i think what they're getting at is
i think in we we kind of don't think
about the fact that
so much of our trade goes through one
chokehold
okay it feels like well surely we can
just ship things all over the place yeah
why does it you know it's just because
the alternatives are the cape of good
hub or the northern passage
like the northwest passage russia have
been bigging up the fact that like you
can come through here there is plenty
all the because all the ice has melted
right they not seen the terror
but yeah you cannot you can go via
russia he's fine there's no
eyes don't worry come this way oh no you
win gulag
that's very offensive what come on you
can't be offensive to the russians
they're our enemies
if we're at war with someone even if
that is a surreptitious cyber war what's
going on right now is that chris is
reading
the third ken follett book about the
cold war in my head we are at war with
russia we're in a cold war with russia
brezhnev has just deposed khrushchev
christiami kristoff has retired first
leader to retire
stalin lenny died in job khrushchev he
peasant
this is what i've been living with for
the last three weeks and if you're not
careful
you'll live with this for next hour of
podcast i don't know welcome
to she doesn't read the news because it
is controlled by the soviet regime
you read what we want you to read
i did read an uh an interesting post by
someone who
was talking about the difference between
six like failing as an author in soviet
russia versus failing as an author in
america
and they're like okay so in soviet
russia if you try and publish a book and
can't get it published you're like oh
it's because
like the the the powers that be are
trying to oppress
my uh my thoughts therefore you know i'm
i'm like an underdog champion
of of the um the unspoken things
in america if you can't get published
you're just a chump
and the thing is actually probably
to a big degree you can't get published
for similar reasons right you aren't
speaking something that
um speaks to the powers that be like the
forces that you know
the selling forces yeah you're not
commercial enough right
so actually they're fairly similar
reasons not to get published but it's
true that in america if you're not
published it's just like
whoa are you suggesting that if you want
to get published you should move to
soviet russia yeah back in the past yeah
yeah yeah that is my
that's exactly what i wanted if book has
taught me anything do not use
same typewriter for writing books that
you do to write your political pamphlets
because they will track it back to you
you must start reading something else
hide your typewriter in cat food
that way no one will ever find it can we
please move on
another big story this week this is uh
all over twitter
uh a man called jensen carp great name
absolutely great sounds like a made up
improv does does and turns out to be not
a very nice man
but uh he tweeted a photo of some shrimp
tails that he found in his cinnamon
toast crunch cereal and
went crazy viral because he was then
tweeting every development of general
mills that manufactures the serial
saying
please send the box for our analysis and
he was replying i know you're going to
make this disappear no i'm taking it to
the police for independent lab analysis
and
he thought he maybe found rat poop in
there as well and uh general mills has
said this looks like
accumulated sugar if if you've been on
the internet you will have seen this it
did look like shrimp tails that have
been covered in cinnamon sugar
and we're just in his cereal which is
disgusting um
i think every now and again you hear
those stories of i had a
finger in my wendy's burger yeah rat in
loaf of bread was one of my least
favorite ones there was just a very
visible
rat baked into a loaf of bread
in the uk oh poor little rat yeah poor
little rat because he probably was
having he was like
amazing i am in a big ball of dough this
is lovely and then
why is it getting so steamy in here yeah
that's a bad that's a bad rat death but
i feel like whenever you you know you
find a hair in your food you find
something foreign in your food it really
does it really does put you off that
meal
um and you're like oh what a shame but
we aren't bloody pampered though let's
admit it yeah
back in the day back in the day easter
eggs five
rats every week well you say but i mean
really it is true you look at like
victorian stuff and it is just like well
you just powder up some fingernails and
put it into the flour and make it
stretch
my my dad used to say that the bread
that we had
the kind of a wholemeal seeded loaf that
my mother
liked um they'd just
drop the dough on the floor of the
bakery roll it round to pick up all the
seeds
and then bake it that's a very old dad
yeah he called it the bakery floor loaf
and i you know um tell that fact that my
my brother keeps telling people which is
incredibly depressing about coffee
oh if you're allergic to cockroaches you
can't have
ground coffee because there's cockroach
look we should tell people the fake fact
i'm sure people
i think enough people now know the fig
facts yeah go ahead your brother telling
us facts is always weird because
whenever i tell him a fact
he did he doubts the fact and denies it
and then goes off to his own research
like i said oh you know that glowworms
are 98
efficient at converting their energy
into light and he said that's not true
that can't be true
incandescent bulbs are only 10 efficient
led modern leds are 50 efficient there's
no weight glow but glow worms are
they're 98 because the first time i saw
a glowworm
i was like oh that's interesting what's
that and then i looked up that's a fact
same telling us facts
i don't know i doubt it as much as i
doubt your mother telling us that
newsreaders are dead
yeah i'm never going to believe her on
newsreaders living or deafness
again yeah that's the thing yeah
so every pretty much every fig has a
dead wasp in it
um but it doesn't right gets kind of
like digested
yeah wasps get laid they lay eggs in the
figs
and then some of them like the male ones
can't get out but the female ones can
chew their way out the male ones don't
have teeth or something so they just die
i don't i don't think you remember
enough details about this but there's
definitely quite a lot of actual wasps
inside
figs yeah figs are waspy so but when
you're crunching on something in a fig
it's not a little bit of water no the
wasp is absorbed exactly it's a
delicious
fig so calm down about it right why you
bother with shrimp tails anyway
it then turned out you know this guy
went viral and within a day
pretty much every one of his
ex-girlfriends and ex-employees are just
like oh this guy is a manipulative
gaslighting fool like he's
the worst and he it was great because it
brought back obviously not great for
them but
great because it reminded us all of the
best phrase ever milkshake duck
oh yeah milkshake duck is a wonderful
internet phrase by twitter use a
pixelated boat
where it's um the first the first tweet
i think was like
look at milkshake duck the duck who
drinks milkshakes
adorable and then the next week is we
regret to inform you that the dog
the duck is racist and it's just that
phenomenon on the internet of like
oh my god everyone loves the the
antelope who eats cantaloupe
the antelope is anti-semitic so
um yeah it's it's that phenomenon of we
all love this person
and then we discover that in fact our
love is is
obviously our love that was based on a
brief snapshot moment of someone just
from one perspective
turns out not to be the full picture of
that person so one of the the most
kind of relevant thing that i was
learning about was so eliza skinner
who's a very good comedian and
and rapper um used to work for this
person
uh on drop the mic which was a show or
pasta mic whatever it was called it was
the the james corden rap battle show
spin-off for celebrities and she used to
write and he was the show runner
and every joke that she gave to him he
was like uh this joke should be about
how that black person looks like a
different black person
she go i don't think that's very
good or funny and he'd go nah that's the
joke it should be and every time they
put in jokes he just kept changing them
to that joke
wow um and after three seasons fired her
despite the fact she was like the head
writer and the person who kind of came
up with the concept and was the main
writer and he was just like
nah i think me a 40 year old white man
know what these jokes should be about um
yeah it was just lovely to see that
sorry no he was he was hoist by his own
internet
fame but were there shrimp tails we
still don't know and he's really gone
quiet on twitter since all his
girlfriends have come out and said
hey he texted me saying why haven't you
killed yourself
your life is worthless it's not a very
nice thing to texting is it it's not a
way to get a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um i don't know if you saw this this was
a viral thing and it and it's all fun
sorry this podcast is not called he
doesn't read the news
okay do you remember that a few weeks
ago there was
a viral email which was a teacher
a professor at a university emailing his
students being like i'm sorry to inform
you that the test is being postponed
um i've i have unfortunately been
shot i have curved and the divorce is
getting really messy
so i'll see if i'm still alive i will uh
administer the test
in three weeks and um so that was the
first email
and i don't really know if this is a
hoax or not i haven't done much research
into it but there was a follow-up email
doing research into fun things on the
internet is only going to spoil you yeah
i don't even want to that's the thing
anyway but the follow-up email was him
being like as many of you have
informed me my last email went viral on
the internet
um i'd like to inform you that the test
is still going ahead to hear the
parameters of the test i'm like my wife
please don't cheat
very good i did is he did he survived
did the test go ahead uh yeah i think so
good because that's the thing where you
look up and then you're like oh no he
died
that's that's sad um
let's move on so we we've had a chat
about this because obviously covering
the news
lots of news stories are very sad and
not very nice and are in fact quite
horrible
um we don't want to not cover them
despite the fact this is a comedy
podcast and so i've invented a new
segment
which doesn't really have a name but it
has a vibe which is it's not funny but
it's an important thing
that happened this week this is the
start of the sad
uh but important news segment if you are
just here for the jokes
then do skip forward uh
to where that starts again which is in
15 minutes we're
broadcasting from colorado about a week
ago there was a
mass shooting at a supermarket a king
super supermarket
in boulder colorado where 10 people
including a police officer who responded
to the scene
to engage the suspect were killed and
the suspect was
taken into police custody and they are
gonna charge him with
first degree murder um pending a mental
hearing um not really many jokes we can
make about this
uh very sad i'm always reminded of the
onion
article uh they turn out every time
there's a mass shooting in america which
when i think about it it's just it's the
most genius headline
um because the onion obviously is like a
satirical newspaper and the headline is
something like there was nothing that
could have been done
says only nation in which this
consistently happens
and they've used that same headline like
17 times now
and i just i i to try and focus
more on the stuff that you and i can
talk about uh i'm really impressed by
whoever wrote that headline
because imagine being told like imagine
the person who wrote that headline like
the first time they did it imagine being
told we need you to write
a satirical onion funny article
about a mass shooting there's you can't
win that right
and yet they managed to find the only
headline that i think is not
disrespectful
particularly because it kind of yeah and
the fact that they keep
using it yeah the murderer did not have
uh a rifle he he had a gun a pistol
a handgun that worked like an ar-15
rifle and it was like an automatic
pistol
like like yeah it looked like a rifle
but it was a pistol
and therefore was able to get around
some loopholes as to rifles have
stricter background checks
um and so you have all the politicians
who are pro guns saying
look title gun register legislation
would not have stopped this
and it seems that every time a shooting
happens they say look it's
bad people who seep through the system
and they're going to find a way to get a
gun if they want to do it other
countries don't have this problem
yeah you know it's just not something
that they're dealing
with um so it does it doesn't
it just feels like it feels like in
america we're kind of accepting this as
a necessary
and it's weird because in the uk we have
hunting people hunt yeah with
powerful guns not semi-automatic rifles
but
they hunt with guns and yeah we don't
have mass shootings
so you can still have guns for hunting
we don't have guns for home protection
that's the thing
no and the reason you need guns for home
protection is because people have guns
yeah and i think that i think a lot of
the argument against
like kind of banning guns outright is
well all the
law-abiding people would get rid of
their guns and all the criminals would
still have guns and then we would all be
you know um ruined by them shot by them
so that's the fear uh i just
i just don't think that the current
situation is sustainable
we had a guy come around to the house a
couple of years ago with he had he had
guns he was kind of
you were so excited yeah he was coming
to pick up a family friend who was here
and he had a load of guns i was like oh
my god you have a load of guns he was
like yeah i was like can i see them
it's like yeah of course sorry was he
holding all these guns like in his
jacket what was the deal
he had just a big bag of guns um
and i he showed me the guns and he was
like this one's really light it's made
out of plastic this is what my
my daughter has she works for the um you
know a federal association she has a gun
i feel really
great safe that she knows she has a gun
um
this is my favorite gun it's like a
sports shooting gun
it's got an extended clip but that's
just for the range it would be illegal
to have that clip
everything you're saying right now um
and so he
he was showing me the gun and your dad
said i said oh extended magazine
enough to you know shoot up a school and
he
and making a joke and i kind of like
stopped myself from going
and then the guy would go in or to stop
someone from doing that
wow and that's the thing that's the
that's that's where you fall on either
side of that right
where when does that ever actually
[ __ ] happen
because i got a text from a friend of
mine on the other side of the world who
was like hey just saw what happened i
hope you and your family are okay and i
said yeah we're very you know fortunate
to
not not be near the area um and then it
was just more
his reply is like it's so [ __ ] up like
there are people who don't get to
respond that to that text
and i was like oh yeah i in my reply i
was like thanks checking this i wasn't
like yeah that's so [ __ ] up oh what a
tragic thing because i
i was like yeah that's that's what
happens in this country
you're dulled down by it and that's well
i think you are but i also know some
people who have really strong emotional
reactions to every time there's a
shooting and it really gets them
freaked out and i i've had i think um
i think i feel more stressed about it
when we're living in a city um
i yeah you get a bit of a sort of
emotional hangover from it because it's
just this kind of
it's it's strange because um it
it's funny how terror affects
your reason because you're still so much
more likely
to die in a car crash or a heart attack
than you are to be shot in a mass
shooting in america right
and yet i don't spend very much time
worrying about
heart attacks i spend much more time
worrying about being shot in the
shooting
yeah good point um so just i think it's
something about about
sudden violence is is just it's because
we kind of have it
we are making the decision of i can be
in a car
i'm gonna eat this burger right that's
our heart health that's our car safety
we have not made the decision you know
it shouldn't be
always your decision to go to the
supermarket and you know there's a risk
inherently there shouldn't be whereas
you know
and that's what we're being asked to
accept by having guns
in the country but you see i yeah i
think the thing is
the people who are pro-gun rights i
don't think they see it that way i think
they think that the
the shootings are inevitable no matter
what and this is the
i think they imagine that the post
gun-banning world would be far more
violent and dangerous and they think we
can't see that they think we're too
naive to see that
i think they're wrong but that's i think
the perspective they're coming from
there's uh now 18 000 unaccompanied
minors
on the u.s mexico border
just like alone 18 000. yeah being kept
in temporary accommodation
such as tenths um
and so these are people who've come
across the border uh illegally
without family um and the
uh the trump administration had a policy
of send them back immediately
whereas that wasn't what previously was
which was we can house them for up to
72 hours and then we'll find either a
family they can stay with
or their actual relatives until an
immigration court hearing
which is what the biden administration
they roll back the trump uh
kind of which seems more humane it does
seem more humane but
it's obviously they're non-humane to
keep them in these conditions which are
right
that's what i mean what what why are
they not doing that why aren't they
finding them families or
well they are it's just there's so many
it's been like a 50
increase since january of people coming
which many republicans have said
is because biden they're coming for you
it's because they know you're
a soft touch and you're going to let
them in which is i can imagine
very much being the case right trump was
super strict so i can imagine you go
oh [ __ ] going there when he's there yeah
wait for there we go biden let's go in
he'll let us in
which you know and it's i mean they
basically just need to
spend more money and get places for
these people to go because i don't see
how you stop it
how just how do you stop people from
fleeing violence
in their countries no you can't and
i don't want to say something ignorant
here but you know the whole
history of america is immigration it's
people coming in
i mean up until i don't i don't know the
history of when we
started putting in immigration measures
but um
in the 1880s that's the first time they
passed like an
exclusionary act where they they did the
chinese exclusion act
i might be getting the numbers wrong
that but i think it's the 80s um 1880s
and they basically said that no more
than 300 chinese immigrants could come
to america a year
um it's a bit bit few for the biggest
country in the world yeah and
particularly given that the chinese
immigrants have been doing some super
useful stuff like building all the
trades continental railroads yeah
so they were very good immigrants people
just were racist
and uh so they had that going on at the
same time as you know
the irish were coming in masses right
yeah and so the history of this country
is
waves of immigration well also how have
we got to the point where people
don't just wholly understand that if you
look at the data
immigration is a net good
for economies for yeah i think i i think
you can't simplify it to that point
i guess that is there are cultural
impacts that i
are alarming and it causes change in a
country and
change whilst inevitable is frightening
so i don't i don't think it's as simple
as like it's good
i think it's very complicated especially
emotionally
but um as i said it's the history of
this country since white people came and
yeah took it from the natives it's so
complicated having lived in los angeles
for
three four years there is a huge amount
of undocumented
immigrants there who every time you
drive past a home depot
there are people standing in the parking
lot
who are willing to do work and there are
people that go and pick them up
and like hey i need you to help move
this thing hey i need my garden fixed
hey
people go and use these these you know
these laborers
illegal laborers off the books but it's
so standard um
there are you know people you know
housekeepers there are nannies there are
people who have come to the country
illegally well with california in
particular california and texas it's
it's particularly dodgy given that like
we
we wrongfully took their land during the
american
the mexican-american war right which at
the time a lot of americans were like
hey this seems not right like this seems
a lot of a lot of americans during this
war thought this was the first
time america had done something evil
which means that they hadn't completely
understood what happened with the native
americans but
um still you know it feels
particularly weird if you're in
california to be like why are the
mexicans coming here when it's like
we came to the mexicans yes
yeah like the reason we took california
is that there was gold there and we were
like oh hang on sorry can we just
oh yes thank you we'll just take that
thank you our final not funny
um but happening story is the the voting
rights bill in georgia which has just
been passed by the republican
legislature
there um which is making it uh
the left would argue harder for people
of color minorities and poor people to
vote because you now need
an a voter id for photo id for mailing
voting there's fewer drop boxes and they
were trying to limit
sunday voting and also um the out the
time you could register for an absentee
ballot i don't think those are now in
the bill
question if you are pro these
restrictions yeah
it's because you think the election was
you think there were fraudulent votes in
the georgia because this is a direct
response to the georgia election
right where two democrats were elected
over two republicans and where donald
trump
lost to joe biden right um now that's a
pattern that's been emerging for
the last few years since stacey abrams
ran for governor and was beaten
but only by a few thousand votes because
uh she and her organizations registered
thousands of new voters which
you know then people will say well
that's not fair you can't
why are you rescued said these people
are you know there's always been worries
about people being struck off voter
rolls and now it's okay so well your
vote's not going to count because you
didn't
correctly vote and republicans say well
we should have secure elections and
yes you should vote correctly you should
do all the things however that makes it
harder for
everyone to vote and therefore people
who have the luxury of time
language grasp uh someone to help and
advise them
they're the people who are more able to
vote and therefore
you are disenfranchising people it just
it is very shitty to be like look
making it harder people to vote makes it
more secure that's fine whereas really
you should be widening
i guess the so the there's gonna be a
tragedy or a flaw
on either side and the floor on one side
is fewer people get to vote and
especially
fewer people uh from like
from economically strapped backgrounds
get to vote
um and the flaw on the other side is
more people might be able
to vote fraudulently and to me
it feels like obviously that that's a
better outcome
but well i mean it's not that it's a
better outcome it's just that
if you look at the evidence of voter
fraud it is startlingly small
i wonder why they don't see that do they
get different are they looking at
different numbers from us well i think
the idea might be that any fraudulent
vote is therefore illegal
but really it does just feel like it's a
way to cover up
the real thing which you know biden
pointed out when i was like well this is
the new jim crow
this is what people are saying and you
know it's
it's it's disenfra disenfranchising
voters of color
it does seem like that and and it also
feels as if what's going
yeah it it feels like it's because
they think well okay trying to get into
the headspace of someone who
thinks walter fraud is rampant they
think
everyone in the country doesn't want
biden it's not it's not a you know
the the country is not actually going
the way it it is going
the country is being tricked into a
direction that is not right for it
that's how they feel
um but yeah i don't know it just seems
it just seems pretty hard to argue these
people should have their vote taken away
from them you know
it's un-american i mean it isn't but
it's un-american idealistic
yeah because i know it's quite to
disenfranchise it's very american to do
that i think i think
i try to think of america in in in terms
of like how america would like to see
itself and how like the founding fathers
kind of thought about america um as this
like shining
place where democracy could grow and
grow and grow and change with morality
and
um and they they had very high ideals
for america
that is the end of the important news
which is not that funny
segment so if you did skip ahead uh then
welcome
back thank you for joining us back on
some funny news but we're going to stick
in georgia right now
because a a man who claimed that he was
owed
910 in wages from an auto
repair shop received those wages when
the owner of the shop
dumped a wheelbarrow full of oil covered
pennies on his driveway 91
000 oil covered pennies what i love
about that
is is how much work it took for that
employer to be that petty
yeah on their website this automobile
shop has a note that says and yes we
accept pennies their cash
so he has been saving up these pennies
for this thing
covering them in oil now the the main
problem is
it took the man who was owed this money
two hours
to clean five dollars worth of pennies
oh no and his girlfriend pointed out he
now has to do
hours more work to get the money for
work he's already done
yeah no i mean if you're that guy it's
not funny it's very annoying yeah you
can't clean penny like to get oil off
it's like birds right you have to
put it in like a bottle of coke is that
what you think works
i think you've been watching too many of
those adverts online where they say
this one simple trick empties your
bowels and it's just a picture of coke
oh my god i got this text message from
it was an advert
and it was like it was like um
upset like getting sick of your huge
stomach
his belly everyone all of your friends
have been talking about your
fat gross body have you thought about
and it was just like
excuse you it's just that one out of the
blue
spam message just really spoke to you i
just thought
we haven't been saying alex you do need
to get rid of your massive belly well no
one needs to get rid of their massive
belly
but uh it was just it was just like uh
i felt much anger at this advertiser
this person who dumped the pennies
um i hope they're
they seem like they probably have some
some rage in their heart so
someone asked him a reporter asked him
was this you
and he replied and clearly the most yes
it was me way
well i don't remember doing it but he
got paid
oh you did that that was you you dumped
those pennies on his driveway
i don't recall that but uh i carried out
my contractual duty
uh love that i get to do my georgia
accent that i learned from a doorman in
new york city
and then remember i was doing it for
some americans and they said
it does sound like you're from georgia
however you do sound like you are a 50
year old black man from georgia
which is who i learned to offer new york
city so there we go um
but uh it's uh you know it's either that
i'm a russian accent you've got to
choose one of them i would really just
prefer your
your natural god-given accent oh
yes shall we both talk like this yes
let's talk about how we're masters
of the uh the creatures in the garden
yeah what have i done um
yeah i've come off quite christianly in
this yeah you have well you're
culturally christian
i find it amusing to speak as if i am a
dickensian christian
yeah you say you're one tragedy away
from going full blown i am one tragedy
away from god squad that's true yeah
not god squad i i'm one tragedy away
from
rejoining the fold of the church of
england which is essentially
just ritual without any kind of uh
because we were both brought up in
british schools
singing hymns and hymns are great
all things bright and beautiful
i loved it our wedding we sang lord of
the dance
yeah chris insisted on them singing the
full version all of us got about six
verses
so long it did it's because i wanted the
thing is you can't just
pick like the fourth verse which is the
one that had they whipped me and
stripped me and hung me high
and laughed at me they're on the
crosstalk i don't think most people are
going to be
uh as invested in hymns as you are
i loved singing hymns in school um but
yes
obviously culturally christian but uh
firmly devoutly atheist not agnostic
pick a side a couple more stories one
involves a
pilot from southwest uh also from the
south
he was uh caught on a hot mic
while flying out of san francisco
airport
berating and insulting the people
and city of san francisco now there is a
recording of this because all
communication between planes and air
traffic control is recorded
however it's really hard to understand
what he's saying but i have got a
transcript and i thought i'd act it out
for you okay
so can you just clarify for me a hot mic
his microphone was on and he did not
realize and so everyone on the plane
could hear no everyone in air traffic
control could hear
okay not on the plane i think there
should be a bit of uh what happens in
air traffic control stays in there
traffic
i think they've betrayed him to be
honest they well it might not be them
anyone can listen in to air traffic
broadcast so someone is doing that
there are many nerdy people alice win in
this world who love to listen to air
traffic control
plane spotting alice plane spot plane
spotting is fairly cool like in a
1940s book where the children always
know all the names of all the planes i
always think that's quite cool a stuka
dive bomb
ah is that from the 1940s or was that
the
great war um no the great war didn't
really i mean they had some
well now that you're asking me about the
great work they did have planes but the
planes in the great wall were very badly
made so you were very likely to die just
in prac you know just when they went up
so for instance there was one man who
escaped from the hullsminden prison
uh during the great halsman and prison
escape of 1918 and when he managed to
get away
he returned to flight school where he
was
um flying a practice plane like in
norwich and it crashed
and they were crashing all the time and
um what was the question
they crashed a lot and just always like
walked it off didn't they
so there was a lot of especially in the
early parts of the war god i
loved talking about the war um so you
know like the red baron
um richtofen yes he killed enemy of
russia
enemy of russia i don't i don't think he
i don't care what the actual stats are i
want to be russian i mean he's not
russian he's a german
he is charming oh baron von richthofen i
didn't think it'd get worse
um it is getting worse so yeah in the
early parts of the war
um there was a sort of courtly like
night
nightly code um because the people
flying the planes were generally
officers so they were all from the same
class
and at least at the beginning part of
the war um
and so what would happen is your plane
would get shot down
you'd land you'd like to burn your
papers you get out of the plane
uh the red baron gets out of his plane
you come and shake hands and he goes
well dude
are you would you like a drink and
you're like yes thank you
and then you go to like the local pub
and then you have a drink and then he
takes it the prisoner of all camp
wow what a lovely wall often you would
exchange addresses
so that you could have like a pen pal
relationship with the person who shot
down your plane
um you would yeah sometimes the red
baron sometimes had a photographer who
followed him around so you can take a
photograph after he had shot down your
plane
that's pretty great yeah very um very
kind of king arthur
knights uh but i think it got a bit more
a bit
less sort of charming um towards the end
of the war
yeah very sad all these old-fashioned
values we've forgotten about them right
when you shoot down a plane have a drink
for the man um so the rant
was [ __ ] this place god damn liberal
[ __ ]
eight guns out here somewhere as it is
there's only that must only be eight
guns since
this game [ __ ] weirdos probably
driving around in [ __ ] hyundai's
[ __ ] roads and [ __ ] that go
slow as [ __ ] you don't have balls unless
you're [ __ ] rolling coal man god damn
it
that was and then then what happens is
the air traffic control just because
it's like oh southwest floyd five six
what what's your position
just just clearly just like we can hear
what you're saying
um that doesn't offend me that much no
it's it's lovely
it's lovely you don't have balls unless
you're [ __ ] rolling coal man
goddammit for those who don't know
rolling coal
is where you um you have a a thing on
your car
which lets you at the press of a button
release a bit of your gasoline into the
exhaust pipe which then burns it and you
put out thick black smoke behind you
kind of like a james bond
kind of screen and it's a thing that a
lot of people in australia do i can't
they don't call it rolling coal i don't
think but over there they do it whenever
they're driving in front of a police car
they do it um so yeah
he doesn't like hyundai's which i don't
know what's wrong with it what's wrong
with a hyundai oh i was gonna say no one
likes hyundai
oh my third car was a hyundai i-10 it
was very lovely
called him melvin not an interesting
story um
uh your breaking news uh breaking news
but
not breaking apart news nasa have
informed us all we're safe from an
asteroid for the next hundred years
how do they know that there was one
asteroid they were really worried about
the length of three football fields
uh which is pretty big for asteroids and
they were worried it was going to hit us
they had a couple of dates coming up but
they were like that's pretty close
and they've now charted the orbit more
and they said oh no it's fine
well that's great news but how are they
supposed to know that there's not going
to be an asteroid that comes out
of nowhere why are you trying to spoil
the party coronavirus is receding we're
getting vaccinated in this country we're
not getting hit by an asteroid
you're right we're gonna get killed by
climate change instead and that's fine
because the northeast passion passage is
finally
navigable right right as long as you're
not haunted by
some kind of cursed monster like in the
terror which everyone
should watch um okay great
that's good job nasa well done nasa so
that is the news alice winn
would you like to tell us something
interesting that you've learned this
week
i've been reading a book about
conversational styles and i've already
told you a little bit about
uh what i have learned but i think a lot
of people don't realize this and the
main takeaway of the book
is that quite often when you think
someone is being rude
or inconsiderate or dominating or
manipulative
they might just have a different
conversational style from you so
um one of the basic differences that can
happen
is to do with pacing so uh i think chris
and i have a similar sense of pacing
in this sense so um to show that i'm
interested in what someone's saying
i tend to try and listen for the moment
when they seem to be winding up their
sentence for when they seem to be
wrapping it up
and then i kind of swoop in and take
over
like it's a relay race and i'm taking
the bat on uh so they don't have to
finish
their sentence right that's um how like
i show that i'm hanging on their every
word
but for some people that just feels like
they're being interrupted constantly
right and some people um
i've noticed this a lot with people in
the midwest um
kind of think that it's more polite to
leave a lot of space around when people
speak
so uh to wait until someone's finished
and then sort of wait another six
seconds before they then start speaking
in case they have something else they
want to add
and uh then they expect you to
bestow that courtesy upon them as well
and
i think this is a really interesting
difference
because i find it really disorienting
when someone gives me a long space after
i finished
speaking because for one thing towards
the end of my sentences like when i'm
wrapping up a thing
i'm really just idly repeating my
thoughts in
different variations you're running in
spot holding the baton yeah
exactly if i had six seconds of silence
that's something i've said
i'd be like oh i just bombed that's how
i yeah because we
both come from a comedy background green
room conversation
let alone on stage improvisation if
you're in the green room just having
conversation with people
if you left a gap people people jump in
to carry on and you then have to do that
you can't wait for that comedian to
finish their story
and then pause and then oh it's your
turn you have to you have to
to them and then take it away somewhere
else but it is really true
that um the the problem with that form
of conversing is that
people who don't converse like that feel
that you're being inconsiderate and rude
right and i remember actually our comedy
troupe friends
at university uh the way that they tried
like if you brought
a friend to one of their parties um
they wouldn't go out of their way to
bring that person in because the way
they tried to be inclusive and polite
was that if you spoke everyone would
like listen to you and laugh at your
jokes and blah blah but they wouldn't
they would assume if you're not speaking
it was because you're shy and don't want
to speak
but they would never be like and what do
you think egg
if someone had a friend called egg born
to my party i think i know what my main
topic of conversation would be
one of my favorite shakespeare lines is
what thou egg shakespeare has some
great insult i would throw a stone at
you but to do so would be to lose a
stone
of athens um that's what that
advertising text
should have been for you they're like
scared of your belly lose a stone
it's a good good pun that isn't it are
we gonna have six seconds of silence
after that
the whole thing is about phobic anyway
um so that was one of the
the differences i already kind of knew
about that because i've thought a lot
about different
conversational styles what the book also
talked about that i thought was really
interesting
was that what we think is polite always
seems obvious and self-evident
and so when someone goes against what
you think is polite
it's really hard to get your head around
the fact that they might also being
polite
and um so this book is called uh that's
not what i meant
and it's by someone called deborah was
it
i keep thinking deborah kerr but she is
an actress from the 40s
so uh deborah says
writes a book called that's not what i
meant look it up anyway
um it's from the 80s and uh she gives
the example of
um let's say that sally goes over to
jed's house and jed says would you like
something to drink what is it with you
in these weird egg
jed sally's fine but and jed says would
you like a drink
and jed is expecting sally to say i'm
not i'm fine
and then jed will go no really do you
want a drink and then sally will go oh
whatever you're having right and try and
make things as easy as possible right
to your coffee and people just go oh
whatever you're having because they're
like they
think you shouldn't make a separate tea
or coffee it's because
um what she breaks down politeness into
two main forces um the
the aim to not impose
and the aim to seem engaged and involved
and basically we have two main
um compulsions as humans right uh women
society
we have the compulsion to be independent
and the compulsion to be involved
right and those compulsions pull at each
other constantly
right and it's a really really fine
balance when you're interacting with
someone
making sure that you're not being too
standoffish so that they feel oh this
person is not doesn't want to be
involved with me
and that you're not being too clingy so
this person goes oh this this person is
you know trying to invade my my
independence
so um yeah the the answer oh
whatever you're having is polite because
it's trying not to impose now sally
instead goes oh do you have orange juice
and judd is like uh right okay
yeah she's rudely rejected that's how he
feels
but what sally is thinking is
it's difficult to have to make choices
therefore sally has made a choice like
and sally is seeing her offer of
sure orange juice as the beginning of a
negotiation she's totally fine with you
being like oh no i don't have oranges
you want tea
that's fine but to jed it seems rude and
if you were to explain that to jed he
would just be like well sure but i think
it was rude
because it's really hard if you think
something is obviously polite
and someone does something that's the
opposite it's very hard to understand
that to them that was polite um and the
book keeps hammering this in and being
like look
most people most of the time are just
trying
to to get along with people and when
they're rude
usually that doesn't actually mean
they're fundamentally rude people think
about it when you're rude
you think of it as you having had a bad
moment and a bad day
when other people are rude you assume
they're just bad rude people
this is how i think when people are rude
because marx aurelius is a genius
begin each day by telling yourself today
i should be meeting
with interference ingratitude insolence
disloyalty ill will and selfishness
all of them due to the offenders
ignorance of what is good or evil
and that is it's a coping mechanism to
not get mad with people because it means
that when someone's rude to you
it's not because they're being rude to
you they just don't understand what
they're doing
is really rude see i think that i i
think that runs counter to what
um good old deborah is saying uh and i i
think a lot of stuff i'm reading um the
meditations right now actually
and which are mark sorely yes book right
i'm really really fond of it it's great
but i do think a lot of how
stoicism works is it's sort of
structured smugness
and it's a smugness that allows you to
feel superior to people when you don't
like them uh which is actually a fairly
decent coping mechanism but that's not
what deborah is saying
what debra is saying is not when someone
is rude to you it's because they're
ignorant
what she's saying is when someone is
rude to you it may be
that they are not being that their
intention what you are hearing
is different from what they think they
are saying right
sally thinks she's saying uh i don't
want to be a pain whatever is good
orange juice would work
what jed hears is sally being like i am
demanding orange juice as new king of
your home
right and so the meta message the kind
of underlying message beneath the words
um can be misheard really easily
and she talked about this with reference
to like uh cultural differences in
social justice which was really
interesting because she's writing in the
80s right
but she says that one of the um
problems with things like affirmative
action in her opinion and she's talking
in the 80s
is that you get oppressed groups
into the room of power but no one in the
room of power has thought about the fact
that they're going to have
conversationally different styles and
they're going to they're going to
like communicate differently and so then
both sides are just baffled by each
other
shielsek is another example um during
the carter administration
uh some americans were asked to rate
like how they felt about the president
of
egypt and um they were all like he seems
like nasty and rude and arrogant
and they were basing this off a new
segment where
um he had said in english something like
um
whether or not mr carter wants me to
come to america i am going to come to
america and sort this out
it was something like that it was about
like a sort of
some beef they had going on in the 80s i
guess 70s
and um the americans were like that
seems really arrogant and rude
but um egyptians were like
that is a english translation of an
egyptian
saying like it's a proverb that's to do
with
um like whatever happens we're gonna
work this out so it's actually a gesture
of good faith
and and like and hope and optimism right
and that's just a classic example of
these kind of mistranslations these
cultural mistranslations that can happen
um and i think what i took away from the
book that's nice is something you do
very naturally
is to not assume people's intentions
because they might just be conversing in
a way that is different from you hmm
that's nice i try and assume
like yesterday when we were driving to
get the vaccine two days ago
your brother was driving and a car
coming towards us flipped us off
now i think it was because that car
assumed we were about to pull out in
front of them
which we weren't we'd seen them coming
and so he flipped off and your brother
was still angry about that by the time
we got back yeah and i was like
maybe they've had a really bad day yeah
maybe
they know that we are getting the
vaccine and they haven't maybe they've
been in an accident lately yeah
may well i said maybe they saw two
handsome young men in the front of the
jeep and thought
i don't like homosexuals like and he was
like no that person would fly off i'm
like it's not because of you
he didn't go oh look there's there's you
there's chris turner [ __ ] you yeah maybe
they did not like my comedy in which
case maybe he's like
look i listened to your segment about
guns and i fully disagree
here's the bird but he was just sound
and i was like
look when people do bad stuff to me
i'm just like oh you must be having the
worst day
but that's the stoic approach but it's
not that i know it's not yeah
but i think it gives the same outcome in
that i'm not it gives it has a yeah has
a similar effect but what deborah would
say
is uh i guess she probably wouldn't
argue that flipping the bird is polite
in that person's culture but it may be
much it could be but
it might be much less rude yeah there
are symbols you know that
like in the uk giving two fingers up
like is
is offensive in america people don't
know what that is yeah um
in you know there are cultures where
like holding your palm out to someone
is very offensive speak to the hand yeah
whereas if you're a restaurant the way
to go it comes to give you some
top of your water and you did that
before you held your hand out they might
then be like
he called me you know i think like
showing your hands and feet in some
cultures is like
you are the devil that's what it means
and it's just so offensive yeah
i mean i don't know why you'd be showing
your hands and feet at the same time
accidentally unless you know if a waiter
um well thank you very much for telling
us about that um
and for introducing us to jed and egg
lovely characters
it is now time for the freestyle wrap of
the week's news based on topics that
alice win
reads out at random from the list of
things we spoke about
today um this is quite a long intro this
is the track by bakery beats thank you
to bakery beats for this
um always bang in tunes alice hello give
me that first suggestion
milkshake duck milkshake duck shrimp
cereal man
no
i know the author so i glow that's the
twitter user pixelated bow
name in that it's a pick for me they
chose that as the word in the dictionary
of that year
from five years ago makes me chuckle to
the day right now
ho ho usually if you get famous on the
web everybody's like whoa you inflating
your head then we find out you were a
bad guy like billy eilish nobody cries
for you thousand pennies oh yes how many
pennies in the pool of oil on your
driveway that's not the right way to pay
someone yeah 415k
that's the owner of georgia automobile
he's like wow this guy was trying to
steal from me trying to take my
wages gonna clean the oil off it'll take
ages getting in rages
they interviewed that horrible weird
nasty dude he's like
so what he got paid doesn't matter he
gotta clean it every day it takes two
hours just get five dollars
if you want a bit of help then sounds
like a pilot
yeah take it off my chest getting angry
when i fly there southwest sw
if i'm in the sfb i'll be like these
guys oh gosh today
they'll be rolling they ain't got no
guns everybody here no fun everyone like
what
all of those [ __ ] freaks drive
hyundai drive so slow takes a week to
get anywhere
not in the mood all the pricks over
there eating whole foods
what about this oh let me check it get a
little bit of boat poetry bread lick
you'll be moving to the side in a
sandstorm all the sailors on side and
their hands warm keeping it
even though it costs a million a day to
keep it flowing on the watery way the
seas sewers get blocked
people like please call the ocean cops
we need them over here
300 boats oh [ __ ] everybody's like we
should vote to eradicate that maybe take
off the containers
people take a long time no brainer still
kind of strain through like a little
sieve and they hope it will move but i'm
not sure if it will asteroids for us
yes we avoid destruction of the planet
by the asteroid all the clever boys and
girls at nasa
they were like guys don't worry no
disaster coming nothing like armageddon
with bruce willis hundred years and
we're still not finished
won't get struck by the mighty stone
everybody you'll be safe in the comfort
of your home
shrimp seriously oh fear and y'all i
want to eat that nice shrimp cereal
and if you get it in your throat there
it's not kosher that would be very sad
won't float my boat like the one in the
canal
i'll be like ah she's general mill why
did you add these
what is this horrible shrimp goo and at
the bottom of the packet there would be
some red poo
that was a fast beat wasn't it it was
good though it was i i liked that one
thank you
good morning to the ocean cops ocean
cops yeah well you got to call the ocean
please
if you see a shark report it to the
water police alice can do an australian
accident
if i say that one phrase hi i'm pauline
henson if you see a shark reported to
the
police it was on it it was on a sticker
on our fridge when we were living in
perth
and i was just like is this something
that they need to do oh yeah
i don't even see a shark reported to the
water important please that is the end
of the episode alice win
um if people like the podcast what
should they do they can find me on
instagram at let them eat books with
underscores instead of spaces and i do
reviews of a lot of the films that we
watch
yeah um and also uh tubs of reviews if
you like it do leave a review on the
apple
podcast app and share it with a friend
um
if you like me you know where to find me
chris turner comedy on instagram
chris pj turner on youtube that's what
i'm talking about that is the end of the
show thank you so much for listening
from me
goodbye from colonel whitachens goodbye
and from alice win goodbye